you mentioned Steve Irvin uh you list a
bunch of Heroes that you have he's one
of them and uh he said that when you're
unsure about a decision you ask yourself
uh wwsd what would Steve do why is that
such a good heuristic for Life what
would Steve do
he's a human being that like everything
we saw from Steve Irwin was positive
everything was with a smile on his face
if he was getting bitten by a
reticulated python he was smiling if he
was you know getting destroyed in the
news for feeding a crocodile with his
son too close he was trying to explain
to people why it's okay and why we have
to love these animals and everything was
about love everything was about you know
wildlife and protecting and to me a
person like that that where you only see
positive things that's that's a role
model and it's just like an endless
curiosity and hunger to explore this
this world of nature yeah and an
insatiable Madness for for wildlife I
mean the guy was just so much fun